alain vidalies sts ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec l' agence france-presse
et dailymotion est avec nous tout à
l'heure karine perret de la sp et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat
monsieur le ministre les chiffres du
chômage viennent de tomber en il
s'apparente à un supplice chinois
supplémentaire j'ai envie de dire pour
l'exécutif dans cet entre deux tours des
élections municipales avec une forte
hausse au mois de février plus 31500
demandeurs d'emploi une première
réaction c'est une augmentation
remarquer 31500 en catégorie a qui peut
être légèrement atténué si on regarde
sur l'ensemble des catégories à b et c
c'est à dire les demandeurs d'emploi qui
n'ont pas exercé une activité à plein
temps sur moi ou sur trois mois on est à
7500 pour pour cela je pense que il faut
regarder ces chiffres avec trois
indicateurs qui sont publiés aujourd'hui
la première indicateur c'est celui d'
activités économiques là les chiffres du
chômage c'est ceux du mois de mars
l'indicateur de l'activité économique
c'est le chômage pardon c'est du mois de
février indicateurs économiques c'est
celui du mois de mars
oui ça repart un peu même bien puisque
c'est la première fois depuis trente et
remarquent pas être technique mais
l'indicateur à partir et quand on est au
dessus de 50 ça veut dire que la
croissance repart on se situer ces
dernières années où depuis ces derniers
mois depuis 31 mois autour de 47 46 51 3
28 et la deuxième raison allez
aujourd'hui dans la presse ce matin je
prends la presse économique du travail
l'écart se réduit avec l'allemagne c'est
pas le résultat du hasard il suffit de
regarder à l'intérieur de cet article
est expliqué que c'est la conséquence du
la mise en place du cicr par le
gouvernement pourquoi je dis ça parce
qu'il faut regarder et répondre à la
question qu'est ce que vous faites par
rapport au problème du chômage si vous
regarder dans le détail des chiffres qui
vont être qui vient de naître
si on regarde dans le détail mais il
faut quand même qu'on retienne le
chiffre essentiel c'est plus de 30000
fraser qui sont basculées s'emballe
catégorie ya ce sont des drames de
savoir qui c'est et ça mérite
un peu plus de précisions je voulais
dénoncer pas celle là avant les donnes
les invite chacun à la réflexion là
dessus
le chômage des jeunes augmente très peu
1500 de plus mais sur neuf mois il
recule il y à aujourd'hui en france un
problème très particulier qui l'a
explose dans les statistiques y compris
ce mois ci c'est les plus de 50 ans
c'est à dire qu'on est dans la situation
aujourd'hui ou sur un an qui est une
bonne période de réflexion
on a un chômage qui augmente pour qui
pour les jeunes de moins de 20 ans
diminue de 1,5 pour cent mais qui pour
les plus de 50 ans et à +12 virgules
alors pour ça c'est vrai depuis
plusieurs mois vous vous envisager des
mesures spécifiques pour les seniors je
pense que la question est posée
aujourd'hui à la fois de la réalité de
cette statistique là et qui entraîne en
plus une divergence avec les chiffres du
bureau international
il faut qu'on regarde ça de près mais je
pense que cette réalité là elle mérite
d'être précisée parce que les gens nous
demandent d'apporter des réponses et on
voit bien aujourd'hui qu'on est
confronté à une exclusion du marché du
travail les plus de 50 ans une
progression marquée un de ceux de nombre
de chômage en france
vous le reconnaissez évidemment je le
disais ce sont à chaque fois des
souffrances individuelles pour les
familles mais ça va encore peser plus
lourd dimanche prochain dans les urnes
enfin la transparence dans la situation
économique cde pas caché les chiffres
cessé de les donner
même si c'est la réalité d'aujourd'hui
et vous savez ce que nous demande le
sort mutilent les concitoyens c'est
qu'est ce que vous faites quel est votre
réponse il y en a d'autres que possible
n'y a pas qu'une seule politique ne la
nôtre et les caire on l'a engagé c'est
pour ça que j'ai parlé de l'activité
économique et j'ai parlé de l'article
des échos ce matin sur le différentiel
du coût du travail avec l'allemagne
c'est soit le résultat du hasard c'est
le résultat de la politique konami à
neuf et je préfère si vous voulez avoir
un indicateur économique va mettre en
avant des éléments positifs on le
comprend enfin l'inversé châssis non
bien sûr
vous pouvez le faire vous même sur les
éléments négatifs c'est aussi votre
travail mais je pense qu'il ya un
ensemble de choses que je voulais finir
ma france et il vaut mieux avoir un
indicateur d'activité économique pour le
mois de mars c'est à dire pour
aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient bons porteurs espoir que
l' inverse alors positif négatif dit moi
le climat ce mercredi matin aux
conseillers des ministres il ne veut pas
être positif
très honnêtement il était assez assez
ordinaire j'ai pas si quelqu'un avances
de l'état est intervenu score des
socialistes au premier tour des mines -
tel était son message le message du chef
de l'état il a été très clair il a dit
dès lors qu'il ya une élection il faut
tirer les conséquences
entendre ce qu'on dit les français qui
ont voté at il ajouté y compris entendre
ceux qui ne sont pas venus voter et il
faut prendre son expression dans sa
globalité et donc il a dit il faut
préparer le second tour puisque c'est le
rassemblement qui doit qui doit
l'emporter explique et encore plus si
c'est nécessaire
ce qu'on a fait mais naturellement il
faudra en tirer les conséquences et
veiller les abstentionnistes de gauche
qui effectivement ont fait défaut oui
c'est toujours un peu le cas par rapport
au parti qui est au pouvoir si on fait
la comparaison avec avec 2008 mais il ya
aussi un message qui est assez simple
c'est que peut penser dans tous les cas
c'est ce qu'on nous dit qu'un certain
nombre de personnes ne sont pas venus
voter parce que les résultats ne sont
pas au rendez vous que la politique
sociale leur leur déplaît donc ce
raisonnement là il est valable au
premier tour puisqu'il n'y en a pas
beaucoup de conséquences au second tour
l'idée de s'abstenir pour faire élire la
droite qui pour le coup personne ne va
prétendre que sur le plan social c'est
là qu'on va trouver des solutions
j'attire l'attention de chacun je prends
un seul exemple on a eu des débats à
l'assemblée nationale
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec la
réforme des retraites qui a été fait par
ce gouvernement mais enfin quand on
ajoute la pénibilité que nous on
maintient à l'accès à 62 ans de l'âge de
la retraite
enfin ce à quoi on a une droite qui dit
non c'est ses 65 ans là on a signé hier
le décret qui pour les personnes qui
travaillent à temps partiel permet
valider un trimestre à partir de 150
heures vous dit tout ça ce sont des
choses qui doivent être président abo
secteur va ça va on a bien compris on
l'a reçu la gifle c'est pas la peine de
nous en remettre une deuxième dimanche
cinq couleurs dites tête une image mais
on peut résumer comme ça on peut la
résumer comme ça selon bruno le roux le
patron des députés ps françois hollande
estime que cette gifle du premier tour
est une forme d'injustice
c'est une forme d'injustice pour vous
savez les électeurs sont jamais sont
jamais injuste à les électeurs qui sûr
que nous ça ne paraît pas effet très
juste pour les autres tenues de sumer
sortant qui ont subi le contrôle
politique c'est normal ils ont toujours
ce sentiment là mais enfin quand on a un
engagement politique il vaut pout rivaux
pour sa globalité
donc si tu peux y avoir ici ou là un
sentiment un sentiment d'injustice mais
suffrage universel n'est jamais n'ai
jamais refusé un gouvernement qui n'est
pas professionnel pas suffisamment
professionnel c'est harlem désir qu'il
dit que presse que vous réagissez
écoutez pas qu'il a comme qualité de
grand témoin pour pour projet de ça on
peut toujours s'améliorer il faut avoir
beaucoup d'humilité dans la façon dont
on dirige les affaires de l'état et de
ce point de vue là même pas l'intention
de donner des leçons à qui que ce soit
ce que je veux dire quand même parce que
je suis témoin je suis en relation avec
les tous les ministres est souvent
compte tenu de ma fonction c'est
franchement tout ce travail et beaucoup
sont très engagés sur leurs ministères
le font avec conviction vous le dites il
ya une appréciation mais je prends ça
comme un encouragement d'accord le héros
bashing amplifiée par des vous des
ténors même du parti socialiste il vous
choque
quel ténor ben on peut veut on peut
quand même je sais que je vais vous avez
vous un ténor c'est votre appréciation
c'est pas la mienne mais on entendu jean
glavany aussi par exemple
ça a été un terrain on a entendu
bertrand delanoë parler d'une claque
pour le gouvernement s'était c'était
différent ils mettaient pas en cause les
reçoit directement je préfère
l'appréciation qui est fait en général
et qui juste de la ce qui est pas
supportable c'est les attaques
personnelles bon de dire attaqué attaqué
un homme
on a mené cette politique le président
la république a été élu sur une ligne
politique on a mené cette politique avec
un premier ministre qui jamais n'a
failli à sa tâche à la solidarité qui
toujours a été pour essayer de dégager
des consensus a vait les groupes
parlementaires qui a été très présent
dans le dialogue
moi je trouve que il peut y avoir des
décisions qui ne relèvent pas évidemment
de l'appréciation des ministres mais
uniquement du président de la république
mais ça ne lui justice à peu se
justifier pour des raisons politiques
pas pour des raisons personnelles alors
on se dit que l'impulsion même le choc
nécessaire passe par un changement de
tête à matignon
ça c'est votre appréciation est-ce
qu'elle sera partagée par le président
de la république je ne sais pas savez ce
n'est pas une règle absolue pour
reprendre votre expression la droite a
pris une gifle à peu près comparable en
il me semble qu'au monsieur fillon est
resté premier ministre on voyait n'y a
pas de règle absolue il avait même
qu'ils avaient même pris une déjà une
gifle en 2004 et monsieur raffarin était
était était premier ministre alors ceux
qui aujourd'hui vont sur les plateaux en
dix ans il faudrait presque qu'ils
démissionnent avant le 2e temps avant le
deuxième tour il faudrait peut-être un
peu de sagesse de ce qu'il est sérieux
le maintien de jean marc ayrault à
matignon est une hypothèse crédible
oui c'est une hypothèse crédible le
président de la république n'a pas dit
qu'il allait changer premier ministre il
n'a pas non plus dit qu'il est confirmé
c'est sa décision
mais voilà le héros bashing n'a aucun
fondement il peut y avoir d'autres
raisons qui justifient la décision du
président est dans tous les cas c'est
lui appartient à lui celles et tous les
autres commentaires me semble inutile
superflue et à vrai dire parfois et
c'est désagréable par rapport au premier
milices dakar en tous les cas il ya un
trio dont on parle c'est manuel valls
laurent fabius claude bartolone qui donc
des convives a déclaré à matignon que
pensez vous de ces hypothèses on n'est
pas candidat à matignon
donc tous ceux qui pensent être candidat
à matignon ils sont candidats à rien
c'est le président de la république qui
choisit le premier ministre donc les
candidatures ne servent à rien et c'est
le président qui décidera est-ce que
l'entrée au gouvernement de martine
aubry si c'est possible
elle serait un bon signal envoyé aux
électeurs de gauche selon vous alain
vidalies si la réponse est est ce que il
faudrait que évidemment que des
personnalités comme ça tout le monde
souhaite ce qu'elles soient à nos côtés
mais martina aubry a répondu que c'était
pas dans ses projets aujourd'hui qu'elle
est dans la bataille pour la bataille
pour lille on a la foi la question est à
la fois la réponse est ségolène royal
est candidate elle est pas maintenant je
ne vais pas c'est pas de ma compétence
et je vais pas faire ce casting que j'ai
observé et que ça risque de vous occuper
encore pas d'un certain nombre de jours
mais pas plus au courant maintenant
apparemment ça peut aller très vite
pensé vous dès le lendemain ou le
surlendemain du second tour des
municipales
mais ça je n'en sais rien je vois que
vous faites des pronostics pour ça fait
longtemps mais il semble que vous
approchez de la vérité voilà ça c'est un
point jean pierre raffarin était à votre
place hier pour ce preuve par trois il a
estimé que le responsable de la montée
du front national c'était le parti
socialiste en raisons de ses échecs que
lui répondez vous je pense qu'il est
plus inspiré d'habitude et que là c'est
probablement l'énervement d'avant le
second tour qui le conduit à de telles
excentricités sur le plan intellectuel
la montée du front national elle a aussi
eu lieu sauf havre une mauvaise foi
totale sous les gouvernements de droite
et elle obéit à d'autres raisons et puis
sur le plan idéologique c'est pas nous
qui avons fait un ministère de
l'identité nationale c'est pas nous qui
avons essayé avec monsieur buisson de
mener mais ce sarkozy de mener une
campagne pour les élections
présidentielles où se demander
ou tel front national où étaient l'ump
avec des propos qui dépassait je dirais
le cadre normal de l'expression d'un
parti républicain de droite mais ça vous
inquiète
le fait qu'il y aura plusieurs villes
front national dimanche sur bien sûr moi
je considère que c'est pas un parti
républicain je le dis très clairement
donc je l' ai déjà dit je pense que
c'est un parti démocrate puisqu'il peut
participer aux élections mais je pense
que ces propos la république c'est
l'égalité la liberté la fraternité la
fraternité c'est pas l'exclusion d'une
partie de la population c'est pas la
stigmatisation d'une partie de la
population et je pense que ça reste un
parti à part parce que il ne répond pas
aux exigences aujourd'hui de ce que doit
être la république mais vous partager
l'opinion de cécile duflot qui lors du
conseil des ministres ce mercredi matin
a expliqué que l'ampleur du vote front
national en fait traduisait une
exaspération sociale
je sais pas si ça peut se résumer cela
je crois que c'est quand même un peu
plus un peu plus compliqué je pense que
c'est une question de peur de dire ce
sur quoi je vous l'extrême droite qui
n'est pas une création des uniquement la
de 2014
il ya eu des périodes de notre histoire
dans lequel des partis de ce type la
populiste honteux pris de l'ampleur et
toujours en surfant sur l'inquiétude des
gens la peur la peur de l'autre ici
c'est quoi c'est la peur de la
mondialisation c'est la peur la perte
d'identité c'est la peur la peur de
l'autre la peur de notre culture la peur
de tout on fait pas une société en ayant
peur de tout et en ayant peur des autres
c'est pour ça que ce parti-là iman
complètement dans l'impasse dans la
division en france on peut pas se
rassembler sur des valeurs qui repose
sur l'exclusion alors le message est que
le message du premier tour a été
entendue c'est ce qu'on a compris de vos
propos jusqu'à présent alain vidalis et
on annonce plus de justice sociale alors
sous quelle forme peut-être que vous
allez pouvoir nous le dire maintenant
on vous allez pouvoir répondre aux
questions de karine perret de l' agence
france-presse
mais il faut quand même rappeler que
françois hollande a un agenda bien
défini pour les semaines et les mois qui
viennent entre le pacte de
responsabilité et puis également le
programme d'économies budgétaires 50
milliards d'euros sous l'oeil de
bruxelles
les explications tout de suite pacte de
responsabilité plan d'économies de 50
milliards maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
c'était l'après municipal promis par
françois hollande
mais comment demander ses efforts aux
français sans en rajouter dans la colère
des électeurs de gauche
pour certains députés il faut que le
président corrige à nouveau son cap
celui fixé lors de sa conférence de
presse le 14 janvier dernier où la
politique que nous menons n'est pas la
meilleure elle n'est pas équilibrée elle
ne reprend pas suffisamment en compte
les attentes par exemple des ouvriers
des employés
mais voilà le gouvernement subit aussi
la pression de bruxelles et l'agenda est
déjà bien tracé la france placés sous
surveillance renforcée par la commission
européenne n'a plus qu'une année pour
ramener son déficit public à 3 % et elle
doit présenter à bruxelles les détails
de son pacte de stabilité le mois
prochain alors à bercy on annonce les
comptes désastreux pour la france pour
le gouvernement actuel
le débat est donc clos et pour le
ministre michel sapin économiser 50
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
c'est l'intérêt supérieur de la france
voilà donc pour ce rappel signé jérôme
monod avec nous vos questions aux
ministres plus de justice sociale
concrètement quel geste fiscal
pourriez-vous faire je pense que vous
avez fait presque toute la totalité de
la question et de la réponse le champ
peut être effectivement le champ fiscal
mais aucune décision n'a été prise ça
veut dire c'est un peu la suite d'une
réforme qui a été lancé d'ailleurs par
le premier ministre une réforme de la
fiscalité des ménages et à du travail
qui se fait aujourd'hui dont on ne peut
pas donner les conclusions
ça veut dire que cette réforme là reste
d'actualité mais on pourrait annoncer
des mesures ou quelques grandes lignes
avant le deuxième tour pour dire qu'on a
compris le message des urnes le m
dernier oui mais l'idée c'est d'avoir
une déclaration de politique qui parlera
à la fois du parc de responsabilité des
économies de la trajectoire des finances
c'est l'inversé de la démagogie jetables
ainsi dire les choses c'est le plan
c'est la totalité c'est équilibré ce
sera annoncé par le président de la
république et il y aura une question va
la responsabilité du gouvernement soient
engagées par le problème
l'assemblée nous préciser la nature de
l'intervention que fera le chef de
l'état à l'issue du second tour monsieur
je ne sais pas si son intervention
portera de sur le détail de ce long
temps pas mais dans tous les cas c'est
une question de jours puisque vous
l'avez vous même rappelé il ya une
échéance à fin avril et à la trajectoire
des finances publiques vis-à-vis de
bruxelles donc chacun sait qu'il y aura
probablement d'ici fin avril dans tous
les cas l'engagement de responsabilité
du gouvernement devant l'assemblée
nationale et que ce moule cet engagement
de responsabilité il se fera sur le pack
de responsabilité mais aussi sur
l'ancien oui mais la question de karine
c'était avant dimanche parce que ce
matin on a entendu au conseil de cassel
nous dire on va pas annoncer entendu ça
veut dire on s'engage à tirer les
conséquences de ce que disent les
électeurs même et une élection ces deux
tours franchement faire des annonces
entre les entre les deux tours ça ce
serait démagogique vous dites oui enfin
très honnêtement je trouve que ce serait
assez mal connu et dans tous les cas ce
n'est pas la conception de la politique
du président et du produit en question
on a envie de savoir quand même ce
qu'est ce que vous avez pouvons annoncer
pour lesquelles je viens de vous dire je
vais pas vous annoncer aujourd'hui ce
que ce que le président de la république
et le premier ministre et diront dans
quelques jours naturellement est-ce que
c'était une erreur par exemple de
supprimer les mesures sur la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
c'était un choix on peut en débattre
mais c'était un choix aujourd'hui est ce
que dans un pays et qui a trois millions
de demandeurs d'emploi c'était
intéressant de dépenser 4 milliards 4
milliards par an pour permettre à ceux
qui avaient déjà un travail de continuer
à faire des enfants la mesure
puisqu'elle que vous annoncez pour les
foyers les plus modestes elle coûtera
beaucoup plus cher peut-être prêt de 10
milliards de revenus vous parle de
politique de l'emploi nous avons fait un
transfert de ces sommes là parce que
c'est à peu près le coude pour la
création de cent cinquante cent mille la
première année 150 me de cette année sur
les emplois d'avenir pour les jeunes si
aujourd'hui on a une maîtrise une
diminution depuis neuf mois du chômage
des jeunes c'est parce que ce
gouvernement a mené une politique
volontariste largement d'ailleurs
critiqué par la droite mais c'est 150
mille jeunes 110 me aujourd'hui 150
mille demain vous parliez tout à l'heure
avec juste raison de ces nouveaux
chômeurs qui si le 30 milles qui sont
dans la difficulté mais c'est 150 mille
là on peut aussi dire en face que ils
ont peut-être retrouver je dirais un peu
d'espoir dans la vie grâce au scanner
pour l'après second tour donc françois
hollande devrait s'exprimer d'une façon
ou d'une autre
est-ce que plus largement il doit ou est
ce qu'il peut et ce qu'il en a les
moyens vu les contraintes budgétaires
bruxelles changer quelque chose sur le
pack de responsabilité sur leucate qui
s'est fixée le 14 janvier j'ai beaucoup
de socialistes le presse de le faire lui
dise il y aura un avant et un après
municipal il faut changer quelque chose
on a le syndicaliste edouard martin qui
le dit aussi
qu'est ce qui peut faire je pense que le
problème qui existait avant les
élections municipales il existe toujours
après donc ce problème il est lequel
c'est que aujourd'hui la france un
problème de compétitivité et que la
france a un problème de déficit du
commerce extérieur
il faut bien que comprendre une chose
c'est que on a une sorte de double peine
qui s'appliquait nous pourquoi parce que
nos principaux partenaires notamment
l'allemagne à l'ensemble de la zone euro
est positif sur le plan du commerce
extérieur et c'est parce que il c'est
positif que laure haut et fort nous on a
à la fois un déficit important et on
supporte coûte 2 euros
et personne ne peut s'exonérer de cette
difficulté c'est pour ça que je parlais
tout à l'heure de la question du coût du
travail
il faut absolument dans ce pays que l'on
retrouve des éléments de combat
idée et ce qui oppose ceux que posent et
chantant ses discours ce qui oppose la
politique de l'offre avec la question de
la une politique de la demande
c'est-à-dire la relance par la
consommation
on peut y avoir un arbitrage
intermédiaires et la question peut se
poser
mais c'est pas une autre politique ou
une politique alternative parce que
personne ne peut s'exonérer de la
question sur la compétitivité et ensuite
ça va être quand on est arrivé on a
trouvé un pays qui avait sur les dix
dernières années perdu 700 mille emplois
industriels
chacun comprend aujourd'hui si vous
remettez si vous relancez la nationale
après parce que ça va être donc le statu
quo sur ces questions là c'est pas le
seul
vous avez déjà aujourd'hui on l'a vu
j'ai parlé du coût du travail 20
milliards du ciel c'est eux qui vont
maintenant rentrer dans la compte dans
les comptes des entreprises pour
favoriser l'investissement les 10
milliards on discute avec les
entreprises vous avez vu au départ il y
avait l'idée est ce qu'il faut d'abord
baissé toutes les cotisations des
allocations familiales ou est-ce qu'on
garde le cic e + 10 milliards est-ce
qu'on voit d'abord sur les bas salaires
ou est ce qu'on voit sur la
compétitivité il ya un vrai débat parce
que si on va sur les bas salaires c'est
plus une mesure emploi ça c'est
aujourd'hui en train d'être débattue y
compris avec le chef d'entreprise à
gauche vous en hausse et une partie de
la gauche de faire des cadeaux au
patronat on a même entendu le patron de
la cgt dire le vrai premier ministre
c'est monsieur gattaz est là est ce que
vous allez corrigé donc le pack de riri
est ce que vous allez réorienter ajouté
je ne sais pas un volet social ou
environnemental opaques les créateurs
les cadeaux au patronat
ça serait sur le plan fiscal quand on
donne aux entreprises la possibilité
d'investir quand il ya des
investissements ça veut dire qu'il ya
des salariés derrière c'est en faible on
fait en aide l'entreprise c'est une
entreprise c'est pas que les patrons
c'est aussi c'est aussi les salariés et
donc je pense que c'est une une vision
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas acceptable
nous sommes obligés d'avoir une
politique d'investissement le volet
contrepartie à ce pack de responsabilité
ce qui sera plus important sur le plan
social sur le plan écologistes comme le
réclament les écologistes qui sont qui
sont sur la vente forcée sur la
transition sur la transition écologique
vous savez que c'est un c'est un
engagement pris par le président de la
république c'est une une pomme texte de
loi qui va venir devant le parlement
je peux vous le dire à l'automne et
j'ajoute il ya une donnée particulière
est nouvelle sur la question de la
transition écologique c'est ce qui se
passe dans la sphère de l'ukraine
puisqu'en réalité l'une des décisions
qu'on va être obligé de prendre c'est de
réduire notre dépendance à la russie est
donc notre dépendance au gaz et que à
cette question la transition énergétique
et écologique devient aussi une
questions géostratégiques
au vu des résultats des municipales
quels sont pour vous les vos pronostics
pour les élections européennes
est ce que le ps risque d'être relégué
au plan de 2e 3e 4e parce qu'il faut ne
pas faire de pronostics je comprends
qu'il ya une inquiétude pour le ps dans
votre interrogation elle est bien elle
est bien légitime et en même temps
savent c'est un lien avec notre débat et
c'est venu naturellement être au
martinet l'avoir posée à ce moment là au
fond c'est là qu'est la vraie question
sur les sur les choix d'orientation soit
ces élections européennes vont se
transformer dans des élections pour ou
contre l'europe
hélas ces fonds national qui va gagner
jusqu au fond je voulais dire ça c'est
un parti dans l'idéologie repose de quoi
sur la peur des gens vapeur de tout la
peur de l'europe la peur de l'autre on
va s'enfermer
autant de choses qui comptent très bien
passé l'arbitré bien sûr mais il est
bien parti pour arriver premier
donc on n'a perdu que les batailles
qu'on m'aime pas je sais les élections
c'est le 25 mai il faudra parler
d'europe
beaucoup parlé d'europe et expliqué
qu'il n'y a pas qu'une seule europe
il ya aujourd'hui des difficultés à doha
il ya des difficultés de croissance en
europe mais parce que il ya une
commission qui est quand même de droite
parce qu'il ya une majorité de droite au
parlement européen et que la question de
ce que la france puisse trouver dans une
autre majorité
en europe la possibilité d'accompagner
la reprise et donc d'accompagner le
choix de la croissance que l'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu fondamental
c'est la même chose
ouais c'est pas la même chose d'avoir
monsieur barroso qui dirige l'europe ou
d'avoir martin schulz et c'est ça qu'il
va falloir faire comprendre aux gens il
ya un vrai choix politique tout aussi
important que le choix qu'ils forment
pour les élections municipales parce que
ça concerne leur vie quotidienne pour
les élections françaises
parce que la question européenne s'est
pas renvoyer certains ne vont pas
vouloir à nouveau sanctionné le
gouvernement au mois de mai pourquoi
vous savez je veux pas interpréter leur
vote l'électeur a toujours raison c'est
de notre responsabilité c'est de la
pédagogie et c'est de la politique ce
que je viens d'expliquer bien je pense
qu'il faudra l'expliquer par tous parce
que vraiment si gens se mettent à voter
pour ou contre l'europe
alors effectivement imaginer ce qui va
se passer quand même si on a un
parlement européen qui est constituée de
gens majoritairement hostile à l'europe
parce que ce dont on parle ici en par le
front national
enfin tout le monde sait qu'il se passe
à peu près la même chose dans les
pédales et dans les autres pays
européens
la montée des nationalismes leur en
vendent email l'histoire se répète pas
moi je préfère être prudent dans ces cas
là on a un grand projet européen qui
pourrait être ce projet remis en cause
par des gens qui ont une vision qui est
uniquement de faire de l'europe un grand
marché c'est ça le fond d'affaires et
les gens ne veulent les gens ils veulent
l'europe parce que c'est un choix
politique mais ils veulent pas que
l'europe ce soit uniquement grands
marchés nous non plus mais c'est ce
choix qu'ils feront le 25 mai en votant
et vous aimeriez par exemple la
commission européenne desserrent l'étau
budgétaire pour ne pas favoriser ses
ventes reculer partout en europe par
exemple ne serait-ce que de modifier les
normes comptables par exemple si on
sortait des déficits des investissements
qui sont des investissements d'avenir
chacun le comprend et il y aurait il y
aurait aucun risque voilà des mesures
mais c'est fait la différence entre la
vision étroite comptable que neuquen
pose aujourd'hui cette commission est ce
que nous demandons avec tous les
socialistes européens
chez les socialistes français ont
l'impression que le feu couve
certains soutiennent mais la marmite est
prête à exploser après dimanche à ce que
vous craignez un grand d un grand
déballage
la curée devait être plus renseigné
comme moi j'aime beaucoup
s'exprimant de personnalités y quand
même entre nous sont quand même
coutumière du fait donc mais aussi des
élus qui calculent qu'ils vont voir
qu'ils seront plus réélu dans trois ans
qui en a qui accuse pour le moment on
n'est même pas d'inquiétude pour
l'adoption le vote aura lieu sur le
pacte de responsabilité mais pas
d'intérêt moi je suis ministre des
relations avec le parlement je suis pour
le respect des parlementaires le
gouvernement aussi est le premier
ministre est très attaché ici un travail
de conviction de discussion ils auront
il aura lieu ce gouvernement n'est pas
fermé à entendre sa majorité est ce que
tu devrais être dit mais ce ne sera pas
une marmite qui va exploser ça sera une
discussion sur qu'est ce qui s'est passé
comment vous avez ressenti des choses
mais au gouvernement parlera aussi pour
dire on n'entend pas que l'ale deux du
parti dire il faut un peu revoir la
ligne tracée par le président de la
république
on a marre qui vont de plus en plus nous
aurons probablement un probablement ce
débat en même temps tout cela va tanguer
- tout ce que j'ai dit moi je suis
confiant ça va ça va pas tomber ça va
débattre c'est une bonne chose
parti socialiste est un parti est un
parti de dédain télé car il rappelé il
ya un instant que les écologistes
finalement ce sont la seule force
politique à sortir gagnant 1 des
municipales dans l'attelage
gouvernemental est ce que ça va leur
donner les droits supplémentaires au
sein du gouvernement le mois tu là
j'étais un peu alors dans l'alliance
gouvernementale majorité la majorité
présidentielle est-ce qu'ils auront un
troisième ministère et ce qu'ils peuvent
prétendre au ministère de
l'environnement tout et les problèmes
dont on vient de parler ce que vous
pensez que la solution à tout ça c'est
de savoir s'il faut une troisième mini
ce l'air sympa pour eux j'ai
l'impression que ça compte
franchement j'ai plus de respect pour
que vous aimez c'est légitime en même
temps ça se présente pas comme ça le
sait le contenu c'est le fond il va y
avoir des débats que y compris dans le
débat avancent leurs arguments oui c'est
pas je veux dire c'est pas c'est pas une
discussions d'épiciers franchement si
c'est vous aviez raison vous vous étiez
dans le sens de ceux qui se sont
abstenus je pense qu'yves il faut
affirmer une autre idée de la politique
assure cassure mais en tous les cas la
composition du gouvernement du futur
gouvernement
cl et dans tout ça c'est bien
loto-québec pas seulement des
journalistes
jouer une un gouvernement avec une
architecture complètement différente des
pôles des grands pôles de responsabilité
des ministres et des secrétaires d'état
se donnent des bacs et qui est posée
pense qu'il est entre les mains du
président jeu juste le fait d'une phrase
un faux débat je lis ou souvent de tels
grands pays à côté de chênois 18
ministres et qu'on a à prendre cette
tout ça il faut 18 ministres il ya 25
secrétaire d'état donc c'est un
gouvernement resserré n'existe pas
vraiment nancy le président peut choisir
notre périmètre
il ya effectivement une expérience de
ces deux années qui peut merci car il
n'allait avant d'accueillir perrine
tarneaud je vous propose maintenant
monsieur me disent allez voir les
efforts que mène un des vôtres un
candidat ps pour tenter de mobiliser
pour le second tour on est à
rosny-sous-bois en seine-saint-denis la
face au maire sortant ump claude
capillon qui est arrivé largement en
tête le candidat ps donc arpente les
quartiers populaires où l'abstention
dépasse allègrement les 50% julien
chollet
ce soir les troupes socialistes se lance
à la reconquête des quartiers populaires
ici auprès gentil l'abstention a atteint
55 % en moyenne pour mobiliser la ligne
de l'opposant numéro un au maire claude
capillon est clair et net
on rentre pas dans la résolution la
politique nationale et c'est rageant que
le message est bien passé au niveau du
gouvernement
le message est bien passé il va y aura
des choses mais on est sur le local 1 le
message est passé le vote sanction a
bien été entendu
alors une fois la porte ouverte place
aux enjeux locaux
les trottoirs les sens interdits les bus
municipaux
tout y passe autant parfois parler du
quartier peut convaincre ça soit la
droite la gauche pour quand on a quelque
chose
le temps pour d'autres la pilule ne
passe pas ancien aller voter non non non
pas du tout
ce 10e ce niveau des présidentielles au
contraire pensent que françois hollande
a quand même compris le message et que
dans les semaines à venir il va y avoir
vraisemblablement des choses qui vont
changer
mais maintenant il s'agit de changer la
vie dans la ville faire campagne en
parlant remaniement décidément
l'impopularité du président pèse lourd
ce qui a été catastrophique et je le dis
sans retenue c'est la communication
faite par par le gouvernement que la
gauche fasse entrer des gens modestes
dans l'impôt qu'ils n'y étaient pas
avant c'est très très difficile de la
faire comprendre que ça c'est cesser
c'est la gauche qui doit le faire au
pied des immeubles une quinzaine de
jeunes interpelle le candidat aucun
accepte d'être filmé ici c'est la
rancoeur qui domine aussi ont voté
françois hollande en 2012 depuis rien
n'a changé alors cette fois et n'iront
pas voter
pourtant dans le local du quartier
peut-être le signe qu'ils attendent
encore quelque chose de la politique
cette petite photo du maire claude
capillon scotché au drapeau du psg il y
aura une quadrangulaire à
rosny-sous-bois dimanche d'enquêté liste
de l'ump le maire sortant claude
capillon du ps qu'on a vu philippe
vacquier riz du modem pierre olivier
carell et du front national daniel
bousselet rhin perrine tarneaud et donc
êtes avec nous soit repéré question à la
vie je vais trouver assez optimiste tout
à l'heure vous n'avez pas peur du grand
défouloir lors de la rentrée
parlementaire et lors des réunions de
groupe des groupes socialistes ici au
sénat et puis évidemment aussi à
l'assemblée nationale quand même vous
sentez pas cette amertume même cette
peine mis qu'un cherche certains élus
locaux qui ont peur de perdre leurs
sièges parce que la cité des élections
municipales mais derrière il ya les
régionales il ya d'autres me terme qui
vont être importantes
sans parler des sénatoriales en
septembre le le combat politique
il s'arrête pas même après une défaite
on parlait tout à l'heure de 2008 la
droite avait connu une défaite
considérables même en 93 c'est la pire
défaite koné connu on a regagné en 97
les élections moi je pense qu'il va y
avoir un débat et c'est bien normal en
plus on en a besoin puisque les
parlementaires notamment sont ceux qui
sont sur le terrain et donc ce sont des
interlocuteurs privilégiés pour le
gouvernement sur le résultat des
élections municipales il va aussi sur le
cap fixé par ce gouvernement où le
prochain gouvernement
public 1 lui qui a été élu sur cette
ligne là et on va le voir sur le banc
oui mais il ya des explications à donner
je me rendais votre reportage
notre candidat dit on ne comprend pas
pourquoi des personnes il y en ait
faible revenu sont rentrés dans l'impôt
pourquoi en assumant sa question qui
quand on écoute les résultats prévient
touré entouré
oui et alors c'est quand même assez
simple de répondre qu'il ya deux mesures
qui sont à l'origine de ça qu'on n'a pas
pu remettre en cause qu'ils sont sains
le gel du barème de l'impôt pour deux
ans quand on est arrivé au pouvoir alors
que les caisses étaient vides et la
suppression de la demi part pour les
veuves qui a été prise avant et donc
quand on est arrivés ou du gouvernement
précédent larmes quand vous arrivez que
entre assumer ce qu'on a décidé nous et
assumer les conséquences de ce qu'ont
fait les autres il est quand même une
marge
donc on peut répondre ça aux gens
d'autant plus qu'ils peuvent nous dire à
ce moment là oui mais vous aviez cas le
remettre en cause sauf que non seulement
il l'avait fait mais campus les caisses
étaient vides
voilà donc ça c'est toute la difficulté
de ce à quoi on a été confronté mais je
peux l'expliquer assez simplement
vengeance est-ce que vous même avez pris
un coup sur la tête dans votre
département des landes moitié-moitié
janvier il y en avait un espoir de
reconquête sur la ville chef-lieu ça
s'est pas bien passé en même temps il a
été élu dès le premier tour
oui tu t'étais sortant il y avait une
seule liste de droite a été élu au
premier tour
en même temps la ville de dax qu'on a
appris que le deuxième but qu'on a pris
en 2008 et donc on pouvait normalement
apparaître comme est en danger notre
candidat a fait un excellent score je
pense qu'il serait vu de ce que vous
avez été vous même surpris par l'ampleur
de ce vote sanction dimanche soir que
personne
vraiment vous venir pas descendez en
tous les cas n'est vous le responsable
vous avez c'est l'ampleur de
l'abstention
l'abstention c'est l'ampleur de
l'abstention qui c'est à dire ce qu'on
appelle le le différentiel d'abstention
c'est à dire l'électorat de droite est
forcément mobilisés depuis 2012 il
attend que ça va venir voter contre tout
ce qui ressemble de près ou de loin à la
gauche donc il l'a fait il ya rien à
dire et l'électorat de gauche mais comme
ça s'était passé dans toutes les
élections intermédiaires sauf que ça a
été probablement un peu plus un peu plus
un peu plus marqué voilà c'est tout mais
c'est pas non plus une surprise totale
ampleur oui les européennes on a parlé
tout à l'heure les élections
sénatoriales
ici on a vu au sénat tout le monde
sortir à nouveau sa calculette et
beaucoup d'où jean pierre raffarin
ancien premier ministre qui était hier
sur un plateau le dise maintenant à
droite ya une possibilité d'alternance
en septembre 2014 au sénat vous y croyez
faut pas tout le monde il ya des
élections il ya toujours une possibilité
d'alternance je vais pas faire des
pronostics d'abord moi je t'invite tout
le monde peut-être attendre le deuxième
tour il me surprend beaucoup c'est que
la droite triomphe comme si on
distribuait les tripes a ajouté monsieur
raffarin
ici ils tirent pour les élections
sénatoriales des conséquences à partir
du premier tour des élections
municipales suffisant probablement quand
même aux jeux olympiques quand même pas
les médailles à la mi temps
jean pierre raffarin on va l'écouter
aussi il est des mots assez durs
concernant le gouvernement sur
l'attitude du gouvernement vise
vie du sénat écouter l'ancien premier
ministre ce qu'il faudra le moment venu
c'est qu'on a une stratégie au fonds
pour sauver le sénat pour rénover le
sénat pour changer le sénat sont érigés
et mais bien sûr qu'on voit bien que le
sénat est en cause aujourd'hui le
gouvernement le marginalise on à l'ap
cependant le sentiment qu une forme
d'indécence et surtout d'amérique mais
ça c'est pas de notre fait
c'est parce qu'il ya eu un partage du
pouvoir qui n'a pas correspondu à un
partage du projet mais alors quelle est
votre réaction est en campagne
électorale pour la présidence du sénat
avant de s'occuper de la gauche
construit faudra d'abord qui s'occupe de
ses propres amis alors l'argument qui
consiste à dire ce gouvernement est
hostile aux sénardes ans mais très
honnêtement moi je suis là toutes les
semaines il ya de bons débats au sénat
se disent qu'il est dans la suite à son
intervention assez intéressante et dès
qu'il ya eu un partage du pouvoir et
senna mais il n'ya pas partage du projet
politique entre vous les socialistes les
verts ou encore les communistes c'est
surtout pas vous n'allez pas découvrir
qu'on n'a pas de majorité ici au sénat
donc c'est une réalité qui explique que
certain nombre de textes ont été
refusées mais il ya procès à faire à
personne à la droite fait son travail
pas au groupe communiste et fidèle à ses
convictions et donc ensuite la procédure
se déroule mais vous savez des lois très
importantes sont passés en premier au
sénat ça pas toujours été facile à
l'assemblée quand j'ai annoncé que la
loi de programmation militaire qui est
important pour des parlementaires elle
serait d'abord examiné au sénat à
l'assemblée on m'a dit à l'inversé si on
m'a dit quand même c'est donner au sénat
un rôle important non nous sommes pour
le bicamérisme très clairement nous ne
sommes pas favorables à la
spécialisation du sénat comme étant la
chambre des collectivités locales pour
être très clair et nous reconnaissons sa
spécificité
non ça c'est la réponse à jean pierre
raffarin sur le calendrier des semaines
à venir le calendrier
parlementaire est ce que dans ce
calendrier bien on va voir l'urgence
économique sociale marquée dans l'est
dans les semaines à venir
vraiment sur le pacte de responsabilité
est ce que ça va venir à l'assemblée
nationale vers le 15 16 avril vote de
confiance comme celles les plus comme
c'est annoncé
non merci de pas avoir précisé l'heure
en plus non ce sera pas dans le courant
du mois d'avril je sais pas exactement à
quelle date le président vous avez vous
avez vous avez la réponse que je sais
pas nickel journée mais ce sera là donc
ça n'a pas de sens donc y aura une
déclaration à l'assemblée avec
l'engagement de responsabilité sur fond
de martigues 49 1 de la constitution
est-ce qu'il faut mettre au rancart
toutes les réformes sociétales et sont
consacrés dans l'économique est bien sûr
je me pose la question sur que non c'est
pas là aussi sont des faux débat
pourquoi faudrait-il faire des choix
entre le social et le sociétal dans une
politique une politique c'est un tout il
ya des textes qui lui seraient le
résultat du premier tour de ces
municipales et bien peut-être que le
mariage pour tous a finalement laissé
des traces dans l'opinion sa à mobiliser
l'électorat de droite
c'est clair enfin le lectorat de droite
je veux pas être respectifs
l'électorat de droite hostiles à ce
texte
mais peut-être à l'éthique de
l'électorat de gauche qui est favorable
justement considéré qu'il fallait qu'ils
se mobilise aussi pour soutenir ces
réformes important donc au parlement
d'ici cet été il y aura des débats sur
la prostitution sur la fin de vie sur la
prostitution c'est prévu sur la fin de
vie c'est pas prévu avant la fin de
l'été pour répondre par là les vacances
pour répondre très précisément président
avait dit quoi le monde déposera un
texte plus qu'on attend un certain
nombre d'avis avant la fin de l'année
de 2014 d'accord une un mot peut-être
sur la visite en france du président
chinois
est ce qu'au nom des intérêts
économiques il faut mettre de côté
toutes les questions sur les droits de
l'homme ça pas les mettre de côté
je pense que quand le président de la
république est allé là pendant la visite
écoutez vous savez très bien comment ça
se passe c'est sont forcément abordé
dans des discussions qui sont des
discussions de chefs d'état chefs d'état
mais elles n'ont pas la france n'a pas
décidé de ne pas reconnaître ce qui est
l'importance de ses relations
économiques avec la chine voit la télé
vers la version pression ils ont écrit à
françois hollande et veulent que
l'ambassadrice de france en chine se
rendre au tibet oui mais ce qu'on
connaît leur position là-dessus mais je
veux dire une espèce de monde idéal dans
lequel on aurait des rapports
économiques et diplomatiques qu'avec des
gens parfaits je respire je le souhaite
peut pas dire ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut renoncer au débat non on sait très
bien enfin que c'est la realpolitik en
même temps la france est porteur et on
le sait très bien et ce ceux qui se
battent dans ces pays pour conquérir des
droits ils veulent qu'on continue à
avoir des relations avec leur pays parce
que c'est la connaît le plus efficace et
que ceux qui s'ils ont une position
radicale se trompent
justement parce que si on n'a plus de
rapport alors la place et est nette et
ils ont besoin effectivement consoneo
connu des interlocuteurs par leur pays
ne serait ce que pour faire améliorer
les choses dans tous les cas ce qui
prime aujourd'hui ce sont les accords
commerciaux y en a une cinquantaine qui
ont été signés à l'elysée pour un total
de 18 milliards d'euros on parlera du
tibet après l'un ou l'autre des droits
de l'homme c'est pas l'un ou l'autre
j'ai cette part se trouve que votre
observation année par n'en parlera c'est
pas l'un ou l'autre il peut il peut être
question des deux choses il ya eu des
positions qui ont été données par la
france en matière politique tend vers
franchement franchement si un pays qui
est au rendez vous aujourd'hui pour
défendre la démocratie y compris quand
tous les autres s'échappe parfois c'est
la france on est allé au mali il y avait
un massacre en centrafrique au nlhe et a
laissé des soldats français je le rends
hommage et c'est la décision du
président de la république alors il
paraît qu'on peut parler effectivement
donné
et au président chinois mais il est bon
de le prévenir par avance donc c'est ce
qui a dû être préparé en coulisses on
verra ce soir tous les cas merci ça
s'appelle de la diplomatie s'appelle de
la diplomatie merci c'est parfois
efficaces et plus sûrs et péremptoire
merci beaucoup alain vidalis d'avoir été
avec nos bonsoir à tous être vite